what is your hope for people reading the
book
and what they ultimately come away with
if somebody walks up to you in the
street two three four ten years from now
and says hey i read edge
um here's what it did for me yeah what
would be the most meaningful thing for
them to say to you
yeah i mean i have gotten so many really
thoughtful
notes already that have been so
meaningful and i think you know
the these these notes and these this is
who i was actually writing as i was
writing the book i was thinking of these
people who
are who are aspirational and believe in
themselves but other people haven't for
whatever reason
and so it's really this message of you
can empower yourself you can flip
all of this you can flip obstacles and
stereotypes and challenges
flip that in your favor and when you're
able to flip that in your favor that's
when you can create your own edge
yeah and it's not this book is not just
for
women or people of color this is
intended for anybody who feels that
they're being marginalized
and who wants to get an edge absolutely
it's both those people who
are trying to succeed and trying to get
somewhere but feel like they can't
i also as i was writing it there was a
number of instances where i found that
um you know parents for whatever reason
will ask professors for
parenting advice because they think that
i don't know whatever um
well you're a professor well yeah and so
they might be able to teach themselves
and i was realizing as they were
sort of asking is that um you know
parents are fighting so hard to try and
give their kids an advantage
yeah you want to talk about an edge yeah
i mean they're fighting so hard we see
instances where parents are like
illegally buying their kids essay
2 scores and trying to get legal yeah
buy them into colleges but on a more
benign in a
in a more legal way like private coaches
extra tutoring extracurriculars
but instead of fighting so hard to give
your kids an edge which might just be
one-dimensional
instead teach them how to so how they
create their own edge
teach them how to create their own edge
so that they know how to go into a
situation and how they enrich
and how they can delight and how they
can guide those perceptions of others
so they have that advantage in every
context today
almost every skill you want to learn is
available on youtube or online or on
coursera or edx or
mit courseware or at harvard business
school harvard business school has
is are all the courses online well we uh
hbx so there's an online yeah yeah
and all the courseware is free you only
pay to get the paper
that's why i understand yeah yeah these
things
if all of the courseware in the world is
out there and then all the prerequisites
are on brilliant.org which were
investors in or
um khan academy on places how do you
account
for motivation and the fact that
so many people who don't feel they can
get an edge
are spending five hours a day watching
television and
just not motivated to add skills or
educate themselves when all this free
education is out there i was looking at
mit courseware recently
and i was watching these videos i'm like
these videos on youtube are
like the huge unlock to getting a job
anywhere yeah in tech
like machine learning course right and
they have 300 000 views and i'm just
like
you know and then some idiotic youtubers
got you know 100 million views for a
video a billion views
how do you account for motivation and
the fact that so many people want to
complain about the system being broken
they don't have an edge the system's you
know stopping them
yet they don't want to go get these
skills which are freely available online
yeah
i mean i always say that everyone can
learn it everyone can learn this
everyone can learn to create their own
edge but not everyone is willing to
and that willingness comes from a lot of
different factors i mean
one factor is that you have to be
willing to be okay with failure and
embarrassment you're going to embarrass
yourself
and the more you and when you embarrass
yourself most people sort of say
ugh like never again i'm never going to
put myself in that situation yes
but that's actually the situation which
you should be doubling down you double
down and like
because i mean we don't learn as much as
we'd like to say like make that mistake
once and then you'll never make it again
i don't know sometimes it takes me two
or three times making the same mistake
before i really get it
and so you have to be willing to have
that humility and that failure and that
embarrassment
to to sort of learn this i mean i think
the the other piece of it is that you
know
we we there's so much information out
there there's almost now
too much and so we assume that we have
everything at our disposal
but really in order to grow you have to
prune yeah and companies have to do this
people have to do this
you have to go back to like what are the
basics what are your basic goods what
are your basic things that really make
you
and companies as they grow and scale
they lose out on this all the time they
start
adding features they start adding you
know
you know different segments all these
things but go back to
what you're good at if you are
essentialism yeah if you are an italian
restaurant and your thing is like
homemade pasta
yeah get it right yeah make sure that
that stays right even as you grow and
expand your menu and do all these other
things i was explaining this to somebody
we were eating in a japanese restaurant
a ramen place and
they were my favorite ramen place in san
mateo and they were like
uh i i uh they don't have like
tempura and i was just like
i you have not been to japan right
they're like no i'm like if you said
this in japan they would say
you're in a ramen restaurant if you want
to pour the
restaurant two doors down is a tempura
restaurant and in japan it's like
the katsu restaurant is the katsu
restaurant and the kobe beef and the
sushi place like
in in america with this weird perception
that like you go to a japanese
restaurant and they're like
there's the katsu and there's your sushi
and
there's your ramen and there's your
tempura it's like
there's no thought of like which one are
they excellent at and you cannot be
excellent at all four or five things
that's right pick
one excellent and deeply excellent this
is what i this is because i get this
advice too like hey talk to my kid
or what should i tell my kid and i'm
like the ability to learn skills
quickly is the unlock like if you can
add a skill in a very short period of
time
it is so impressive to employers and so
effective when running a startup
and i was just having a meeting before
we got on air with a founder who just
was a hardware founder who taught
himself all the sales and marketing
stuff
yeah and he's doing much better than you
know the
the vp of sales like this chief revenue
officer that would cost three or four
hundred thousand
because they just took this three to six
months to learn everything about sales
and marketing
in the whole funnel this is the unlock
it's just learn being
able to learn these skills quickly yeah
yeah i mean and it's so critical because
you can't be excellent
at six things at once no and and so
that's the sort of
you have to prune in order to grow as
you're growing and trying to get bigger
keep going back to what are the one or
two things that you're really really
good at
keep building from there just like a
tree right if you the tree wants to grow
you got to prune away the the extra
stuff so that you can grow
you can't have like 50 limbs that are
all the big thick ones that you know
it's like
maybe this three or something right